puffins are like a variety show a
cabinet yeah yeah because like she said
we have hundred languages we still live
in one family households so the grand
moms they're the grandchild is there the
great grandchild is there and all of us
watching cinema is the only escapist
route we have in our country we don't
have skins clubs we don't have car
racing we've got a little bit of sports
coming in our television just started so
what happens is you need to have that
area where you want to say listen I'm
not bothered about life or these two and
a half hours I'm going to be overwrought
by this fun and the GRANDMONT says I
want to hear actually something
spiritual so we put spiritual and and
she says I want to see this cool guy
with dimples dancing it's okay
and you say I need to be startled so yes
totaling you so we we put everything in
it you know and and unabashedly so yeah
and happily so and celebrate life
because life I think has all of it put
in you know life has never been that you
don't sing you think while shaving and
have a fight and there's no isolation of
emotions in real life everything is
happening together and it's wonderful
when I see Western cinema that it
isolates emotion this more linear
there's more storytelling there's more
character-driven stuff but I think a
cinema because it's just celebration and
celebrated it makes you feel a little
attracted to it you know you say okay
let it be now let something else it down
and what does it have fun a lot of
technology from Hollywood people like
myself and the younger actors and
directors want to take it on because I
think technically the Western cinema is
about 40 to 50 years ahead of us and we
need to bring it to India that's the
only way we will be able to come down
come up in the international market we
are about zero zero two percent of world
market as far as economics go we didn't
make the maximum number of films but in
terms of economics we are very small the
only way we can do that is not change
the language of our films the technology
and the technique of storytelling you
know we do it and we have we do films
and three acts we have an interval you
know as I was I have to tell you this
incident I made a film called Ashoka
which was about
Gautam Buddha an assault is a great firm
I thought and unfortunately sorry to
have to mention it I'd released on 9/11
so it kind of Tang didn't do well and I
was I was showing it to an English set
of audience just before I came here and
and and the film went on and on and it's
really long we make three hour long you
know and so before they all entered so I
had all these British people think why
do you guys have the interval a way of
doing what does it mean wait
why should we why should we have to
break into the air it breaks the whole
sequencing of a story turn so I said I'm
sorry but we have an interval after one
and a half hours they were like holding
my hand why don't you guys have the
interval now so our cinema looks after
everybody's wants and desires as well as
in when they crop up